did you know that 70% of processed foods
that we eat has at least one GMO
ingredient in it and most corn and soy
in the US is genetically engineered and
there's corn and soy in everything there
are GMO crops on half of us agricultural
land maybe you don't care but most of
you do only 37% of you the general
public is cool with GMOs even when 80%
of scientists pulled
say there's nothing to worry about both
sides of the debate admit the issue is
not so clear-cut to GMO or not to GMO
let's get into it
to keep up with population growth the UN
estimates that the world will need to
produce 70% more food in the next thirty
five years but anti GMO errs say that
production isn't the problem its
distribution inequality politics waste
and conflict are the real reasons that
people go hungry but they're so hard to
solve why not let supercede save the day
Pro GMO or say GMO seeds can give larger
yields under tougher conditions and
withstand insects disease and herbicides
they also say GMO seeds use fewer
pesticides but USDA research found that
the most widely used GMO crop Monsanto's
Roundup Ready soy resulted in 527
million more pounds of pesticides
sprayed in the US not to mention that
glyphosate the key ingredient in the
most popular herbicide roundup has been
linked to diseases like Parkinson's and
cancer these health concerns are huge
reasons why many people don't trust GMOs
they've only been in supermarkets since
the mid 90s but most studies so far
haven't found evidence of GMOs being
harmful to humans there's not a single
cases of harm to human health or the
environment and 20 years of genetically
engineered crops and 40 years of
genetically engineered medicine but
there are scientists who say we should
be more concerned about the
environmental impact like the loss of
biodiversity you know plants and animals
dead zones caused by fertilizer in the
oceans the contribution of Agriculture
to climate change
the majority of GMO seeds come
four giant corporations who run the food
industry and corporations are about
making money not necessarily about
sustainability biodiversity or people's
health opponents worry that the rise of
GMOs will lead to an even more
industrialized food system one that they
say is already flawed it's one that's
led to disease displacement worse than
climate change and pushed out small
farmers on that last point while GMO
seeds might be making life easier for
some farmers they are more expensive and
they've got patents so some farmers are
being priced out and some are even being
sued for using seeds without permission
proponents say that's the way the cookie
crumbles and we should innovate or we'll
be missing out so when it labeling foods
that contain GMOs appease both sides
more than 60 countries require GMO
labeling but not the us here
corporations spend millions to defeat
initiatives to label GMOs yeah so should
we keep innovating and eating and ask
fewer questions or should we slow down
and she wanted a little this is some
terrible news cuz I just learned that
climate change is actually threatening
cocoa production which means less
chocolate for people who love it like me